last night he was all Brook Lopez how
about that
take that Laker fan oh my gosh and
joining us right now from Chicago days
after the draft lottery drama and in the
midst of the NBA combine Sports
Illustrated's Chris Maddox are you Chris
think about what you just said there is
no Brook Brook Lopez in a Conference
Finals game all Brook Lopez and this is
a guy I've covered for a long time in
the New York area
the fact that he's reinvented himself as
this defensive stalwart flash
three-point gunner is really a
remarkable story yeah cuz he did it on
both I me as Marv was saying he was on
fire in every facet of the game he was
defensive as you said stalwart but
blocking shots and making threes and
given that stare down to the camera and
it was awesome it really was great to
see wow there they finished the regular
season the number one defensive team in
the NBA and Lopez was a big part of that
and he was always a good defensive
player when he was in Brooklyn but there
were times there in New Jersey as well
their time there where he had to be off
the floor in key situations because
teams went small and big lumbering
centers don't do all that well he's he's
adapted and you know it's a credit to
Mike Budenholzer and and what he does
with his system but you know Brook Lopez
is a guy that you can play every minute
in the fourth quarter because he'll
defend at a high level and he'll be able
to knock down threes like it's our last
night well and in terms of me saying
take that Laker fan I mean John horse
the general manager the Bucks pushed a
ton of buttons in the offseason and
they're working out I mean did you
imagine if Lopez did in fact go to the
Lakers this year instead of the Bucks
would what the difference might have
been right there and I mean I mean this
is John horse who I think is just now
legally allowed to buy beer like John
horse is it is if he's not the executive
of the year he's right up there with
with the top two or three I mean it
seems simplistic to surround Yanis with
high-level shooters but he's the first
one to really do it in the Yanis era
in Milwaukee you went out there and he
identified Brook Lopez who remember the
first I think six years in Brook Lopez
his career he didn't attempt a
three-pointer the last few in New Jersey
and in LA he was attempting a bunch of
them but he identified Brook Lopez as a
volume shooting three-point guy and
Brook Lopez averaged six and a half
threes this year and he was a factor in
in making Yanis the MVP same thing with
guys like earth-sun ilya silva some of
the other pieces they added I mean he
went out don't a team around Yanis
that's a real credit to what John did in
a very short time on the job all that
said obviously it's just a game one Kyle
Lowry was sublime last night he was
terrific and that said if it wasn't for
him the doors would have been totally
blown off in the fourth quarter in
Milwaukee because Kauai couldn't get a
blow and that's I think maybe the the
story so far of the Toronto postseason
is it's been too much Kauai and then
when it was finally not all Kauai they
still couldn't pull it off Chris what do
you think about Toronto's chances moving
forward here in this series yeah I don't
I don't look at Toronto if I'm the
Raptors I'm feeling okay about the loss
and you know yeah they needed Kyle Lowry
to go crazy and it's unlikely does that
again in the series but it is
increasingly likely that Kauai has
another you know phenomenal game or a
bunch of phenomenal games left in him
I think Pascal siakam can certainly play
better and he's a key to what they do
the bench guys who've been key to what
they do all year they're gonna play
better and this Raptors team was I think
it was an eight-point lead going into
the fourth quarter I mean they blew it
and are as much as we praise Brook Lopez
is it likely he gets what was the twenty
nine points again in the rest of the
series I think if you're Toronto you
gave them a tough fighting game one you
put yourself in great position to win
game two and if you do that going back
to Toronto which one of the toughest
places in the NBA to play where the
Raptors have had tremendous success all
season long I still think you're
reasonably confident going into the
series if your trial you can win Chris
annex of Sports Illustrated back here on
the Rich Eisen show all right Chris as
you know I'm well-versed in the NFL
Scouting Combine never been to an NBA
combine what in the world does it look
like it looks like something that they
should blow up and never have again it's
become kind of I'm looking I'm not
well-versed all on the NFL part of it
but throw in the NBA for last years and
maybe even more than a few now guys just
don't participate
I mean I'll talk to your guys I mean
it's become a very low-level event I
mean some guys show up you know the
lottery guys they'll show up but they
should want to do medical testing they
show up to do interviews with teams some
of them do media availability but we're
not going to see Zion Williamson over
the next couple of days you're not going
to see you know John Morant and camreta
share a court for the next couple of
days I mean you're just going to see
Prince first and second-round picks play
in the five-on-five portion everybody
else is just going to get measured out
there I mean it just it's it is lost a
lot of value when it comes to evaluating
the top-tier picks because the agents of
these guys don't see any value and
having them go out there and participate
in in five on five their position is
that we've got 30-plus games and in some
cases multiple years worth of tape on
our guys we're not going to risk them
going through this getting burned and
seeing their draft stock drop so the
thing has become kind of a a great event
for second round picks not so much if
you're looking for action from the
top-tier guys well then then maybe it's
similar to the NFL Scouting Combine and
the fact that all the evaluators are in
one place and the media is in one place
and everybody's talking there's a lot of
chatter chitchat chitchat rumors and
conjecture and how about that guy or did
you hear about this one what what is the
main talk around the NBA combine right
now Chris well that's I mean that's what
it effectively is both in the room at
the combine and in the bar rooms already
kind of congregates and and hangs out
it's still
I think everybody is still kind of
letting the dust settle on what happened
in the lottery and trying to figure out
exactly what it means I mean there was a
bizarre narrative yesterday that maybe
Zion goes back to Duke and I was seeing
that you know I know there was some
stuff on ESPN about it and I it was all
over social media I mean that's just
that's insane I mean died on first of
all to familiarize I mean I'm sure you
know some of this but like guys yeah you
don't lose the players right if you
draft him and he decides not to play for
you so if science stays in draft gets
trashed by the pelicans
he's a pelican for life unless they
trade him he can go back to Duke but
that seems just bonkers given that
injuries or whatever can change the
course of his life plus he has no idea
who's gonna draft him next year the if
he stays in the draft it could be New
Orleans again for all he knows with next
year's lottery so that's kind of what
people are talking about and you're
already seeing today like you know some
reports about Zion having a positive
meeting with the pelicans they're gonna
take him and then I think people are
sort of talking about where the dust
settles after that John Marant is pretty
solidified as the number two pick to
Memphis I think RJ Barrett is pretty
solidified as number three to New York
and after that I think it's chaos
because you're gonna see some trades
you're gonna see some teams that aren't
overwhelmed by the talent that exists in
three to ten and that's where I think
things start to heat up yeah I mean with
desired stuff I was saying yesterday and
I'm sure repeated again here on the show
today and the way of me telling you here
is that have we read into the mind of a
young man with our own thoughts or
conjecture and rumor more than with Zion
I mean when a shoe exploded we were all
saying of course he's thinking about not
playing at Duke anymore he's got to
protect himself for the draft lottery
and of course he came back and he played
in the NCAA tournament now we're sitting
here thing of course he doesn't want to
go to New Orleans and he's gonna try and
figure out a game away to be you know
like Eli Manning or John Elway and to
use the NFL analogies of somebody saying
I don't want to go play for that team
maybe just a young kid who's just
excited to play basketball and he's
ready to go to the NBA and you know
obviously the question is what does New
Orleans do here Chris
well I mean I agree with you that he's
he's a guy that just wants to play
basketball maybe plus he's a kid from
the south - so playing in New Orleans I
don't think he's unappealing to him and
I love the people that are you know you
know if he if the Knicks got the number
one pick the first thing the Knicks
would do would you try to trade him to
New Orleans so he might wind up in New
Orleans anyway you know because of the
Anthony Davis aspect of all this the
pelicans rich they're gonna draft him
and then they're gonna let the chips
fall where they may I don't think that
and I talked to David Griffin about this
the other night that the public stance
remains we're gonna try to convince
Anthony Davis to stay privately they
know Davis doesn't want to be there
who's not going to sign an extension and
it's too big a risk
to keep him on the roster all season
long if you don't have an extension in
place you just can get too much value
back in return but what the draft now
does and the lottery does it slows the
timetable down like they can take their
time they can drop Zion go into July
wait till free agency dust settles and
then decide where to flip Anthony Davis
I don't think it goes beyond the summer
because I think his value decreases and
the increase of injury is still there
with Davis but I think this is the kind
of deal that unless they get overwhelmed
by something you're gonna be in mid-july
maybe late July with Anthony Davis still
on the pelicans so what this does is
give David Griffin a little bit of
breathing room to make the Zion draft
pick and to figure out what he wants to
do what they'd be well with the way that
the ping-pong balls bounced and settled
Chris Mannix of Sports Illustrated here
which do you think which situation do
you think is affected more Anthony
Davis's or Kevin Durant's on July 1st
Chris I think I mean it's good question
I think Kevin Durant might be affected
in in a roundabout way
I mean if Zion went to the Knicks and
either they kept him or traded him that
would have been another incentive for
Kevin Durant to want to be in New York
now you know if they do draft an RJ
Barrett who you know nominally plays
kind of the same position as Durant what
does that mean
I'm not honoring too much into a graphic
and what it means for Kevin Durant but
with Davis III think that he was always
going to get traded this shakes up the
board a little bit when it comes to who
can offer what the Lakers put themselves
I think in a much better position they
know it with that sports taking the
draft they can now couple with their
other players Boston certainly is
looking at the Lakers making maybe that
offer is going to need to be trumped if
they decide to go all in on Anthony
Davis so I think that that with Davis he
was always going to get dealt it just
changed a lot of things the types of
offers he can that can be made and last
one for you you you are closely covering
the Celtics what do you think of Terry
Rozier 'he's first take tour and what it
does in fact mean for the Celtics in
this offseason looks like they're
certainly not gonna run it back Chris
right no yeah no I well it's unlikely I
would say I don't think anything is
impossible when it comes to that
organization I you know and I talked to
a few people in Boston after Rozier did
what he did they were too bothered by it
they felt that he was kind of even
inexperienced or a TV guy who kind of
got caught speaking off-the-cuff a
little bit on these debate shows that
he's really not all that familiar with
but all that being said you know Terry
Rozier didn't do himself any favors
coming into free agency he you know
burned a little bit of a bridge with
Boston I don't know if it's entirely
torched but it's a little bit scorched
and for every other team out there Terry
Rozier effectively said that unless I'm
gonna be a starter I'm not gonna be
happy so if there are teams that are
looking at him as you know kind of a
combo guard backup or whatever and I'm
willing to pay maybe they rethink that
observation now Rozier might want out of
Boston rich but I don't know that Danny
Eames gonna let him like he's a
restricted free agent and Danny Ainge
comes from the 1980s he played
basketball with bird and McHale parish
and he played on teams that didn't
always like each other but they won
because of their talent Danny Ainge has
always been about accruing as much
talent as possible and Rozier for all
those warts is still a talent so as much
as he might want out of Boston I think
the Celtics are still gonna be willing
to match a lot of offers that come his
way Chris I would say enjoy the rest of
the Scouting Combine but I got the drift
you're not a big fan so
well I'm not a fan of the of the the
whole process it's fun being out here
everything's in one place and you can
you know kind of catch up with whoever
you need to catch up with I would just
like to be sitting there and see you
know cam reddish and RJ Barrett
teammates at Duke go at it in a
five-on-five setting or my face just I
guess just a I guess extrapolate this
out before I let you go I mean in the
NFL you know the top number one overall
pick quarterback Kyler Mauri didn't
throw there but he did show up obviously
and he'd do anything except the
measurement and the interviews and all
that sort of stuff but pretty much
everybody else does
that said if they played like an 11 on
11 scrimmage or some sort of seven on
seven
I think agents would raise their hand
say there's no way we're gonna let them
do something physical so if the main
engine of evaluation at this combine is
a five on five I can kind of see what
what everybody's talking about plus if
there's only what 60 draft choices to
like in the NBA and look the the one but
the problem too is that this is kind of
bled into individual workouts as well it
used to be where agents would allow guys
to you know you know play against each
you know other talk to your prospects in
closed setting but because sometimes
that stuff got out and guys look bad
they don't do that anymore so you've got
you know basically what you the
pageantry of this week and then when
guys individual workouts it's you know
man verse chair or man verse room
shooting jump shots over you don't see
that individual stuff which is
unfortunate because that's another part
of the process I like to hear about by
the way that's one of my favorite under
used words in sarcasm is pageantry Chris
well done I like that yeah thanks to the
call Chris appreciate it you gotta read
you yeah that's Chris Mannix at si Chris
Mannix on Twitter here in the Rich Eisen
show for more of the Rich Eisen show
tune - audience Channel 239 on DirecTV
for free on BR Live or download the Rich
Eisen show app